i love this too i might you might i
might blind you
that's your tactics
so here's the thing okay you eating
canada that's us oh my god take a second
right i'll take a second yeah cause you
don't have it are you canadian yeah i
didn't hear any accent really we're
blending it well we're just like
i've been here for like four days so
it's totally gone
how's that eh no no no
well we're talking about the scrolls
right okay how can you tell if someone
is or isn't this where like i see paul
rudd over there i'm thinking of yourself
well right it's this he hasn't aged and
yeah oh that's true yeah
i don't think that's a clue because i
think that they're smarter than that and
they would probably manipulate their
skin to age and become more believable
but i think that the only way you can
really tell is you know do they bleed
red or green
so you have to get violent you have to
choose violence to find out
straight up start cutting people to make
sure and that is like i mean but that
honestly when you think about that and
you think about the world that is secret
invasion where are we gonna go right how
do you how do you decide how do you how
can you figure out who is a human and he
was a scroll you got dark we get really
dark yeah in this show
listen you've been there we've been
watching you since the avengers okay
like you're
like well thanks for that anyways 27
years ago um it was just yesterday yeah
and
when you see new people come into the
mcu is there like do you talk to them
about like what they expect do they come
to you and ask you about my gosh no i
mean
it's it's a whole new world there's so
many new uh people coming in amazing
projects so much diversity i'm so
excited about it and i on and i honestly
can't even keep track of all of it but i
you know i
i'm
i want to chat with anyone who'd be
willing to ask me anything but everybody
is everybody who they hire is i mean an
excellent and
and are putting together cool
new types of projects so it's just like
you know they don't need me
they need you but i'm happy to give out
any i remember when in my day
and you couldn't i was just a young you
know
and it is exciting it's really cool to
see so many new people come in and and
the story is just there's something for
everybody you know what i mean there's a
there's a story line that everybody can
relate to and everybody can watch and
and it's thrilling and it's all very
confusing and you come here to comic con
just like literally just to get the game
plan like oh that's what we're doing
i mean i'm just i'm just really happy i
had that scroll question that that green
blind question i was like yeah i know
that
i know something
i'm glad you didn't try and stab me
thank you appreciate that
not yet
thanks thank you